let's get into the mailbag if you have
something to say you can email info
davidpackman.com sometimes we will pick
something from a YouTube comment or a
Twitter message or whatever the case may
be I want to start today with someone
who feels very very strongly
about Donald Trump
even after Trump's announcement that he
is running this individual JR says
Trump's not running JR says he ain't
running he can announce all he wants but
he's ultimately not running I'm so sick
and tired of his big fat miserable ass
enough already either stroke out or have
the big one and die I don't care die old
bastard die already this is very
aggressive when will the Decades of coke
and meth abuse finally get him I'm over
at America is I'm over America is over
it just at least have the dignity to go
off somewhere like an old cat or dog be
your fat old self and croak already
please spare us any more of your ugly
misery so Jr is exhausted by Trump
but I have to tell you I believe that
he's running that being said we talked
earlier in the week about a path in
which a failing Trump campaign
prematurely ends
before the first primaries
and we explored that in detail earlier
in the week I don't think it's
completely implausible one other comment
about Trump 24 from Nathan the subject
is magaga
Nathan says in his announcement Trump
said he will make America great and
glorious again will he Rebrand his
movement to magaga
very good question I don't believe he
will but there should certainly be some
kind of rebranding the current branding
is really not so good on the topic of
getting men out of women's sports as the
Wright loves to say Alex had a really
good thought
Alex said hey David I don't believe
Trump would even have the power to ban
trans individuals from participating in
the sport Association that lines up with
their gender identity
aren't Sports associations private
entities if they allow a trans male to
female to participate in a sport
formally consisting of majority CIS
women that is their own choice with all
due respect Alex yeah that this is
actually a very good point so there's
two issues here there's they claim to be
about small government conservatism and
yet on social issues there's no one that
wants more government involvement than
they do the truth is that all sorts of
different athletic organizations have
already had systems established to
determine who can participate and and
what does it mean to qualify to compete
as a woman this is this is not a new
issue even though they want to make it
seem like it is it's not a new issue
it's been around for a while and many of
these leagues have already dealt with it
before those running leagues that have
dealt with it there are weightlifting
around the world okay so it's not not a
new issue secondly they say we want the
lightest possible touch from government
government should only be involved in
anything when it is absolutely necessary
and in the public interest
and one of the things they want to
choose is who is in which sports league
so that's part two it's not really small
government and number three is
absolutely correct that with many of
these leagues they are completely
private the one area where some legal
Scholars say you you might be able to
kind of crowbar government in would be
when it comes to State College athletic
programs
things involving Title IX and in some
other narrow circumstances but this is
another very good point which is it's
not even clear that legally whatever
Trump imagines he would do on this issue
aside from it being bad faith aside from
it not even really being an issue Scott
Galloway on yesterday's show told us
that in South Dakota they were passing a
law about this and that there is not a
single instance of a quote men and
women's sports that they've actually had
to deal with yet they want to pass a law
about it
um a lot of problems with with all of
this and let's hope
that Donald Trump never even ends up in
the position to do it Steve wrote in
about the fact that all of those people
that travel around the country to all
the Trump rallies they weren't invited
to Mar-A-Lago for Trump's big
announcement Steve writing in Trump fans
from rallies not invited to Mar-A-Lago
David sir I found it interesting when I
looked at the crowd of people that
attended the 2024 announcement at
Mar-A-Lago that none of the typical
Trump fans that we see at his rallies
were invited could it be that Trump
doesn't like to hang out with his
faithful rally goers listen I have said
this before not that we needed more
proof but I have said before
Trump doesn't like the people that voted
for him Trump is a rich guy from Queens
Manhattan spent most of his life away
from the folks that ultimately became
his constituents and trying to be
nowhere near a lot of those folks and
now he has built this Persona where I
mean think of it at age 68 he suddenly
is religious at age 60 80 suddenly
against abortion he likes uh the boaters
of Florida he likes country music none
of it is believable it is all a
character necessitated by the reality
that Trump couldn't win a Democratic
primary because there are some standards
in the Democratic primary I'm not saying
that the standards are amazing or
anything to write home about but there
are at least some standards among
Democratic primary voters among
Republican voters there are absolutely
no standards and that's why Donald Trump
had to run as a republican despite the
fact that he was probably really a
Democrat for most of his life next email
is from Greg and Greg brings up
something that I think is completely
implausible Greg says Trump DeSantis
2024. David I write to you with tears in
my eyes and fear in my heart I'm very
afraid that Trump and Des sanctimonious
will make up in time to join together on
a ticket in 2024 with the promise that
Trump will back DeSantis in 2028. do you
see that as a possibility
I really don't you know sometimes we
look at some of these scenarios and we
say statistically there's some sense to
it Trump and DeSantis right now each
have roughly 40-ish percent of support
depending on which poll you look at it's
50 30 or whatever for the Republican
primary the math of it should be
DeSantis supports Trump
on the understanding that Trump chooses
to Santa's VP then DeSantis has a path
to be president in 2028. the math of it
makes sense what doesn't make sense is
ego and narcissism will not allow it
Donald Trump's ego and narcissism and
maybe to some degree Ron desantises I
don't believe will allow that scenario
to become a reality if you disagree with
me let me know I'd be curious to hear
from you John wrote in John wants to
talk to me about guns
John wrote in saying I own 24 Firearms
many of them assault weapons hello David
I'm a strong supporter of the Second
Amendment I was wondering if it would be
possible for us to have a conversation
quote on your show I don't know why
that's in quotes about what the role of
guns in our society should I'm guessing
it means should be including kinds of
guns people should own including assault
weapons Etc I promise I will treat you
with the utmost respect while I would
consider myself a strong conservative
man I'm glad that it's he's not just
conservative he's strong
I am generally open to other people's
ideas and feel I can be persuaded if I
feel a person I'm talking with can make
a sensible argument my number is blank
hope to hear from you soon by the way
please blur out my number yeah listen we
take calls once a week and you can call
in this isn't exactly the type of call
we would schedule but John I would love
for you to call in when we are taking
live calls and then we can chat about
your perspective on assault weapons I am
curious why someone needs 24 guns maybe
you're a collector I don't know but
that's that's an open question Carolyn
wrote in about an issue with Instagram
and this this is horrifying that this is
going on I've told you about this before
but it's still happening Carolyn says
hey I know you're having you were having
problems with Tick Tock due to malicious
reporting it appears that Instagram may
have also taken some sort of action
along the same lines as I received an
error message on the app stating the
following David Pacman show can't be at
mentioned because they have repeatedly
posted content that goes against
Community guidelines on false content
about covid or vaccines
Carolyn says if it's a problem you're
aware of I apologize but I've been a
member and a listener I don't recall you
mentioning yeah this is this is insane
there's no way to appeal it
Instagram's appeal process so here's
what happened basically we published
videos debunking misinformation about
vaccines
they were flagged by Instagram as videos
pushing disinformation about vaccines
which means no one can tag us on
Instagram when we try to appeal it
there's an appeal process but you have
to submit the videos in question that
caused the problem but those videos have
been removed so we quite literally
cannot file an appeal so I appeal to you
in the audience and really with tears in
my eyes
if you work at Instagram Facebook meta
if you can help with this I'm desperate
for your help our Instagram is being
hindered dramatically
because people can't tag us and they
can't share our content in that
particular way
if you can help please email info
davidpackman.com we have a great bonus
show for you today
we will talk about so many different
things huge announcement
our white paper on talking to family
on at Thanksgiving about things you
disagree about
is now live and available for free we
produced a guide which you can get at
davidpackman.com guide for free I'm I
have nothing to sell you here it's a
free guide people call in all the time
they say David how do I handle this that
conversation
we have like it's like a 10-page paper
got really really good
davidpackman.com guide read it before
your Thanksgiving conversations let me
know if there are things that should be
added modified whatever
free if people like these we will do
more of these guides we have a great
bonus show for you today join pacman.com
to get instant access I hope to see you
there